there's a thing on the internet where
everybody wants you to go on a date
dated so many women and he's sort of
cute could Martha Stewart and Pete
Davidson be Hollywood's next it couple
he's sort of cute he's like my lost son
yeah sorry internet Martha says not so
much it's all in fun on Tuesday the
lifestyle experts stopped by the Drew
Barrymore show and weighed in on fans
who want her to date the Saturday Night
Live Alum after giving Pete and his
tattoos a hypothetical dating green flag
your date has as many tattoos as Pete
Davidson
green flag red flag yellow flag uh-huh
I knew it
knew it is Pete Davidson
the unlikely Duo went viral after they
were pictured holding hands at the White
House Correspondence Dinner earlier this
year where Pete was in attendance with
his then girlfriend Kim Kardashian he
stated so many women so what no I'm not
saying that's bad I think that's good
and he's sort of cute
everybody loves them and she's not wrong
in fact back in April Kim and her famous
family revealed what they loved most
about the comedian what do you love
about him what's your favorite thing
about him he's just super genuine and
it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing that's the goal
is finding someone to do nothing with
it's the best because you don't do
everything with totally but it's easy to
be distracted with people you can be
with anyone distracted but you can't be
with anyone and do nothing but back to
Martha hang out with younger people
that's another secret is to hang out
with younger people turns out she
actually knows Pete he was on the beaver
roast with me do you remember yes he was
this little twerp of The Beatles
he was even trophier than Bieber
foreign
well I I got it it was also very cute by
the way you
met back in 2015 during comedy Central's
Justin Bieber roast I'm talking about a
Playa in the boardroom and a freak in
the bedroom
it's first of all everybody in the world
wants to see this kid get roasted and
you know
he's been [ __ ] up a little bit so
this will make people like him again and
Martha she's a fan everybody speaks
about Pete Davidson in such a positive
way like he has to be a good guy oh he's
a good guy he's a very good guy and he
knows he knows how to get in and get out
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but Martha says fans who are shipping
the two shouldn't hold their breath he's
open to you know age is not a thing for
him saying
he's like he's like my lost son okay so
meet Martha and Pete not gonna be a
thing but this isn't the only hot take
the TV personality has dished out lately
I don't feel my age I don't look my age
I don't act my age Martha made an
appearance on last week's episode of the
Kardashians and weighed in on Tristan
Thompson's cheating scandal during a
chat with Chloe keeping it short and
sweet I don't read and watch all the
stuff so do you have a husband I don't
no I don't I just broke up with my
daughter's dad oh a little bit ago he
had a baby with someone else while we
were together oh that's not nice we had
to kick him out it's not nice that is
not nice it's awesome it was very
naughty
[Music]
thank you